e andare incontro al futuro con la
determinazione non soltanto di credere
alle nuove idee
d
parecchie
quando parliamo di passione parliamo di
creatività ci rendiamo subito conto che
queste sono queste due questi due
vettori che portano a innovazione io
parlerò di innovazione sociale però
ovviamente quando spalla di innovazione
viene viene facile pensare al futuro io
sono cresciuto con goldrake anch'io mi
sono chiesto anche con guerre stellari
sono cresciuto anche con star trek e
avevo questa visione fino
all'adolescenza di un futuro che era
molto così come vedete in quest'immagine
un futuro fantascientifico
astronavi città che crescevano in questi
deserti semi lunari senza apparente
relazione con l'ambiente che le
circondavano man mano che sono cresciuto
ho cominciato a occuparmi di di
sostenibilità ed innovazione mi sono
reso conto che queste visioni avevano un
fondamentale problema non si può
scollegare il futuro dal pianeta in cui
noi viviamo dal pianeta terra del
pianeta da qui da cui dipendiamo la
visione del futuro che adesso comincia
ad emergere in maniera sempre più
pressante e prepotente intorno a noi è
questa di nuovo un immagine di londra
che non ci sta che torna oggi a bologna
più volte però un'immagine diversa
un'immagine di un futuro che potrebbe
essere anzi che probabilmente sarà se i
sistemi socio economici che ci
circondano non cominciamo a cambiarli
non cominciamo a lavorare seriamente su
una riduzione per esempio degli
idrocarburi che compiamo nell'atmosfera
e quindi fermiamo il fenomeno del
cambiamento climatico
una città sommersa e simbolica quello
che è più importante riconoscere che il
50 per cento della popolazione globale
vive a ridosso delle coste e quello che
succederà sulle coste del mondo domani
avrà un impatto fondamentale
immaginate se metà della popolazione
mondiale deve prendere baracca burattini
e spostarsi al di là del perdere il
lavoro perdere la casa significa un
dissesto per tutte quelle altre città
che le dovranno accogliere ecco un'altra
immagine di londra un'immagine dei
parchi reali che sono diventati dei
campi profughi non ci portiamo più il
nostro cane la domenica a correre quel
bambino in carrozzella perchè ci vivono
milioni di persone che sono state
spostate dalle loro case
come le visioni del futuro di prima oggi
non hanno tanto senso secondo me c'è un
problema anche con queste visioni del
futuro e qual è il problema fondamentale
di fronte a questa immagine voi vi
sentite paralizzati cioè voi vi sentite
improvvisamente che non avete la
capacità di agire per influenzarlo
questo futuro per questo io quando
comincia a pensare al futuro a parlare
al futuro parlo di immagini e uso
immagini che sono più simili a queste
queste sono immagini voi mi direte non
di un futuro lontano in realtà sono cose
che probabimente avete visto anche voi e
è il mondo che ci sta ci sta circondando
ma che è un'immagine uno spaccato come
un'alba del futuro che sta per arrivare
sistemi di mobilità sostenibile energia
rinnovabile e telefoni cellulari che noi
utilizziamo in maniera più impensabili
oggi in africa tutto il banking viene
fatto attraverso telefoni cellulari
ecco dietro a queste che noi chiamiamo
innovazioni sociali stanno cambiando la
nostra vita ci sono delle persone
questa è la prima cosa che vorrei che
voi portate via della mia presentazione
non immaginiamoci l'innovazione come
qualcosa di astratto sono persone come
voi come me che a un certo punto
seguono la loro passione e fanno quello
in cui veramente credono
la differenza tra questi innovatori gli
attori sociali inoltre i classici è che
loro al cuore della loro passione hanno
la risoluzione dei problemi reali che le
persone e il pianeta hanno oggi pensiamo
alle donne in africa che devono ancora
trasportare acqua sulle loro sulle loro
spalle sulla loro testa per nutrire la
loro famiglia per cucinare per lavare
per bere immaginate quanta acqua potete
veramente è realisticamente portare
sulle vostre spalle ogni giorno
ed ecco che qualcuno si inventa un
sistema molto più fruibile per
trasportare acqua sette volte più acqua
di quella che una donna riesce a
trasportare normalmente immaginate come
le cambiata la vita a questa donna alla
sua famiglia e al suo villaggio pure
immaginiamo manila le baraccopoli che
circondano la capitale filippina
le case sono talmente ridosso le une
dalle altre che non riesce neanche a
penetrare la luce del sole ed ecco che
qualcuno si inventa una cosa che ormai
geniale una bottiglia di plastica
riciclata ci mette dentro dell'acqua un
po di candeggina ma così non si formano
delle alghe e poi taglia un buco nella
lamiera di tetto del tetto di lamiera
del della baracca che in questo caso
vedete in modo tale che alla luce solare
riesca a penetrare attraverso la
bottiglia e diventi una lampadina cioè
questo per me è geniale allora a me
quello che interessa molto e questo è il
mio lavoro abbiamo un po a quello di cui
mi occupo io come si fa andare da idea
ha impatto questo percorso in realtà che
abbiamo fatto semplice qua in realtà è
la cosa più difficile del mondo è quella
su cui in questo momento tra l'altro si
scervellano scienziati esperti
imprenditori
comuni governi cioè quel passaggio tra
un'idea geniale che abbiamo tutti sotto
la doccia la mattina ha effettivamente
fare qualcosa che che avrà un impatto
sulla vita del vero delle persone del
pianeta ecco io ho tirato fuori questa
formula è la formula che noi utilizziamo
all'interno della nostra rete per
ricordarci quali sono degli elementi
chiave l'elemento chiave è la
collaborazione ma ci arriveremo in un
secondo
il primo importante è riconoscere la
fruibilità dei luoghi
un luogo è una cosa importante perché
mette insieme le persone ci sono diverse
tipologie di luoghi che possiamo
elencare c'è la silicon valley di cui
vedete l'immagine in alto
oppure c'è ed è quindi possono essere
luoghi permanenti possono essere luoghi
temporanei possono succedere come sta
succedendo questa giornata oggi è
mettere insieme le persone significa
farla e collaborare fars cambiare idea
significa creare un contesto è un
contesto di innovazione
il secondo elemento è una comunità
allora in questo momento nella stazione
di bologna ci sono tantissime persone
però loro non sono una comunità quello
che abbiamo qua sono delle immagini
invece di realtà che sono diventate o
sono nate come delle comunità potrebbe
essere il movimento di critical mass
ciclisti che si oppongono alla
automobile krazia che domina la nostra
città oggi
oppure potrebbe essere un gruppo di
persone che come in questa immagine a
glasgow organizza orti urbani e che si
sentono accomunati da questo desiderio
di lavorare su questo può essere il
movimento occupy wall street che avete
sentito nominato più volte e che è
diventato nell'intento politico che
aveva una comunità reale può essere
anche una cosa come un flash mob vedete
qua un'immagine presa a boston nella
stazione di bosto di persone che si sono
date appuntamento per prendere cuscinate
anche un evento ludico può essere una
comunità ma la comunità va creata e va
coltivata
il terzo elemento sono contenuti di alto
valore
non basta un luogo non bastano persone
messe in questo luogo l'importante che
gli si dia da mangiare
altri contenuti e questo crea un
contesto di innovazione e generativo
molto molto forte l'esempio un po
classico da fare un posto come l'italia
il rinascimento italiano
ecco una penisola ecco delle città ecco
una comunità di persone principi artisti
scultori filosofi papi accomunati da un
contenuto di alto valore e che
cominciano a propagare tra l'altro con
un mezzo di diffusione relativamente
nuovo il libro che permette al
rinascimento italiano di essere
velocemente esportato nel resto del
mondo
che cos'è l'elemento che fa la
differenza oggi oggi l'elemento chiave è
la collaborazione se noi vogliamo che
queste idee veramente decollino
diventino impatto per tutto il mondo noi
dobbiamo cominciare imparare a
collaborare e la parola collaborazione è
rivoluzionaria oggi un mondo che ci ha
insegnato fondamentalmente
l'individualismo e la competizione dire
che no dobbiamo fermarci dobbiamo
cominciare a lavorare insieme è un
fondamentalmente per me è una è un atto
rivoluzionario
però non è facile
non è facile perché la collaborazione è
una cosa che stanca è una cosa difficile
e lavora bene siete accorti anche voi
molte volte lite ma perché questa cosa
non la faccio da sola il fatto che se
facciamo le cose da soli quell'immagine
di londra originaria che voi vi
ricordate diventerà reale quindi
dobbiamo arrivare a un mondo diverso e
dobbiamo arrivarci tutti o non ci
arriverà nessuno io però tre storie che
vi presento qui oggi e che se come
incapsulano quello che si può fare
quando si collabora insieme la prima
succede in israele l'estate scorsa e
denny che è un è un mio amico come tante
persone in israele di fronte al
malcontento di fronte alla situazione
drammatica del proprio paese decide di
prendere un tavolo e di metterlo davanti
al suo ufficio
un tavolo lui si siede e invita
sconosciuti a sedersi al tavolo a
cominciare a parlare della situazione in
israele oggi di come cambiarla quell un
tavolo diventa 1000 tavoli in una sera
in tutta israele 10mila persone si sono
sedute intorno a questi tavoli per
parlare di come in sé rail e potrebbe
diventare un paese migliore
nel futuro
il primo atto della collaborazione e
sentirsi liberi di poter esprimere le
proprie idee e le proprie passioni e
questo è quello che denny ha fatto in
israele un anno fa un atto veramente
secondo me è eroico un'altra mia amica
tatiana non ha solamente avuto una
conversazione e l'ha trasformata in
azione come tante altre persone nate a
toronto lei sa benissimo che nel lago
ontario non si può fare il bagno è un
giorno è seduto in fianco al largo con
la sua mica keren e e vedono dei turisti
che si infilano nell'acqua e dicono cosa
stanno facendo questa questo lago è
inquinato e comincia una conversazione
tra di loro sull'importanza dell'acqua e
del riff i care le acque del canada
dall'inquinamento questa conversazione
diventa azione diventa un organizzazione
che si chiama what you lucian e water
luce nell'arco di nove anni organizza
più di 300.000 seminari sull'importanza
dell'acqua in canada e centinaia di
progetti partono tra le persone che si
conoscono
all'interno di questi di questi seminari
un atto la condivisione di un'idea porta
una collaborazione e ad un'azione
il terzo esempio che vi faccio non
potrebbe non venire dal lavoro che
faccio quotidianamente
questa è la rete di travo una rete di
centri e di persone che si occupano di
quello di cui ci occupiamo molti di noi
in questa sala oggi di innovazione
sociale innovazione che fa bene alle
persone e fa bene al pianeta ecco
proprio che dell'immagine dei punti nel
mondo dove noi abbiamo dei centri che
diciamo dice a un certo punto chi siamo
questa è l'immagine che secondo me in
capsule più di tutto il valore della
nostra rete perché siamo persone
prendiamo da tutto il mondo e il valore
del nostro lavoro è dato dal fatto che
da 32 città del mondo 55 persone
riescano a mettersi in un'isola a questa
immagine è stata presa in svezia un mese
fa circa e a collaborare per tre giorni
per migliorare il lavoro che facciamo
respira
io volevo concludere dicendo la
collaborazione chiave se noi vogliamo
salvare il mondo e come dice un vecchio
proverbio africano se vogliamo andare in
fretta
andiamo da soli e se vogliamo andare
lontano andiamo con gli altri mi
ringrazia